Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, this
is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another episode
of The Tim Ferriss Show, where it is my job to
deconstruct, or at least attempt to deconstruct,
interview, shall we say, world-class
performers from all different disciplines.
My guest today, I feel for me, has been a
long time coming. I'm very excited to have
on the podcast Dr. Gül Dölen. Dr. Gül Dölen is
an associate professor of neuroscience at the
Johns Hopkins University School of Medicine, and a
pioneer and world leader of psychedelics research.
Her laboratory has discovered a novel mechanism
that could account for the broad range of
therapeutic applications that psychedelics are
currently being tested for. Her lab has discovered
a novel critical period, we'll define what
these things mean, for social reward learning,
and shown that this critical can be reopened
with psychedelic drugs such as MDMA, LSD,
psilocybin, ketamine, and ibogaine.
Building on this discovery, she has
formulated the hypothesis that psychedelics may be
the long-sought master key for unlocking critical
periods across the brain. To test this hypothesis,
she's initiated a nationwide collaborative
effort to determine whether psychedelics reopen
critical periods for ocular dominance plasticity,
birdsong learning, anatomical plasticity in the
barrel cortex, serotonergic neuronal regeneration,
dendritic spinogenesis, and motor learning. If
you don't know what those words or phrases mean,
don't worry, we will define them as we go.
Importantly, understanding psychedelics
through this framework dramatically expands the
scope of disorders, including autism, stroke,
and allergies that might benefit from adjunct
therapy with psychedelics, an approach she has
dubbed the PHATHOM project. That's P-H-A-T-H-O-M,
which stands for Psychedelic Healing:
Adjunct Therapy Harnessing Opened Malleability.
Dr. Dölen earned her MD PhD at Brown University
and the Massachusetts Institute of Technology,
and otherwise known as MIT, where she carried
out seminal work on critical periods, learning
and memory, and the pathogenesis of autism.
You can find her online at dolenlab.org. Dr.
Dölen, welcome to the show. Nice to have you.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Thank you for
having me. It's nice to be here.
Tim Ferriss: So I thought we might
start with your undergrad experience,
and I have read that you designed your own major,
and I was hoping you could describe how one
designs one's own major and how you thought
about going about designing your own major.
Dr. Gül Dölen: I've always been somebody who
learns best by comparing. And originally I
thought, well, I'll just do a triple major of
neuroscience and linguistics and philosophy.
And the university was like, "No, no, there's
no triple major. You can do a double major,
but if you really need all three, we recommend
that you do this, design your own major path."
And so I worked with my professors in philosophy
in neuroscience primarily to come up with a
curriculum that would span all of the different
elements that I wanted to incorporate in trying
to ask the question, "What is the mind? What
is consciousness? How do we know that from
different perspectives?" And so the major was
called Comparative Perspectives on the Mind,
and it was a combination of neuroscience,
philosophy, linguistics, art, religion.
And really the idea was is that this is something
that humans care about. And so we've thought about
it from all of these different perspectives
for millennia and what can we understand from
that approach?
Tim Ferriss:
Why were those questions — and hopefully this
doesn't sound like a stupid question, because at
face value perhaps they should be interesting
questions to everyone since, on some level,
I suppose consciousness is fundamental —
but why were these questions interesting,
compelling to you at the time enough that
you would attempt to have a triple major?
Dr. Gül Dölen: I have to say I'm not really sure
why exactly those, compared to everything else
that I saw other people majoring in like economics
or history, I just didn't care about those things
the same way as I cared about. I've always wanted
to only study or think about things that I think
are deeply interesting that I would want to talk
to with anybody. Whether it be the person sitting
next to me on the bus or my parents or somebody's
kid. I like thinking about things and when I'm
obsessed with something, I just think about it all
the time in every context. And so I just never had
that with economics or history or any of the
other topics that seem to be popular majors.
Tim Ferriss: Didn't cause the quickening.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Right.
Tim Ferriss: There are a few terms that
may come up later, we'll see. And I'd love
to have you just expand on them or define them
because I was reading in prep for this and you
briefly considered marine biology, but you were
also interested in philosophy of mind and then
a philosophical consideration called theory of
mind. What is philosophy of mind? How should we
think about it? What is theory of mind?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Philosophy of mind,
it's not really a branch of philosophy
or anything, it's just a thing that
has drawn the attention of philosophers from
a variety of different perspectives like you
can imagine considering what is the mind from a
metaphysical point of view? So what are the things
that we count when we say this is what a mind
is, this is what a mind is not. Then there are
other considerations like, "Well, how do we know
mind? Can we know mind just through introspection
or is there some empirical way or some way that
we can compare different people's descriptions
of those things to get at what is mind?" And
that would be the more epistemological approach
to mind. And I was interested in all of those
things. There continues to be debate about that.
And one of the interesting ideas that I came
across was this, that there was this concept
of theory of mind, which is not really a
theory in the way that we have a theory of
light or a theory of synaptogenesis or any of the
more commonplace theories. It's more like it's a
point of view. The theory of mind is just — the
shorthand way of explaining what theory of mind
that I like to tell people is, it's sort of what
you're doing. It's the neurobiological process
that is going on when you're playing poker.
It's anticipating what somebody else might be
thinking and trying to see the world from their
point of view. So in some sense it's a theory
about what somebody else might be thinking.
And this ability to understand or to have a
concept of what somebody else might be thinking
is something that we develop and we get better
at as we mature. You can always tell when a kid
is starting to pick up theory of mind, it first
comes on around age four or five because they
start doing these funny pranking behaviors where
they'll reach around your back and tap you on the
wrong side and look the other way. And that's them
sort of playing with the idea that their own
point of view and the person whose shoulder
they're tapping might be different and that they
can trick somebody by playing on that difference.
And so this theory of mind, there was some
idea out there, I'm not sure that it's really
a dominant theory right now in autism, but there
was an idea that this is something that people
with autism are not so good at and it makes them
bad poker players, it makes them bad at lying,
it makes them bad at tricking people. And
it's this thing that psychopaths, for example,
are very good at. They have better-than-average
theory of mind, and they use that better than
average theory of mind to manipulate people
by anticipating what they may or may not like
and using that information to try and get
whatever it is that they're trying to get.
And so this theory of mind idea was out
there and there was some idea that, "Well,
you need to have theory of mind in order to have
consciousness, in order to have a full sense of
knowing who you are compared to other people."
And I like this idea because it was a testable
hypothesis. And one of the things that I found
frustrating about being a philosopher is that
the philosophers were always asking the
coolest questions, the biggest questions,
but just felt like they were just going around
in circles and never really coming up with an
answer that I found to be deeply satisfying. And
on the other hand, scientists, neuroscientists,
maybe they weren't getting to ask all the
really big questions, but man, they were
coming up with some concrete answers that felt
like tangible and like we were getting somewhere.
And so I like this idea that we could test the
requirement of theory of mind for consciousness
by looking at diseases where that function
is impaired and learn something about the
relationship between consciousness and
genes that encode different proteins
that are required for that theory of mind.
Tim Ferriss: I have many, many follow-up
questions. Theory of mind does not seem
to be — based on the reading that I've
done — entirely human-specific. And is it true
that you have observed this in, for instance,
and your tapping on the shoulder made me
think of it, hunting behavior in octopuses?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Those were actually not my
experiments. Those were experiments done by really
imminent octopus researcher Roy Caldwell. And
he showed me the videos of them and as soon as
I saw the videos of the octopuses hunting,
it occurred to me that is exactly a theory
of mind-like behavior in an octopus. And the
reason that that was so interesting is because
the way that people talk about theory of mind is
that this is a behavior that evolved due to the
selection pressures imposed by social living. So
when we have to live in a social group, it serves
us to be able to anticipate what other members of
that social group might be thinking in order to
anticipate and either compete or collaborate
or whatever it is that you're trying to do.
And octopuses, by and large, are not social
species. So if you put two octopuses of the same
species into a tank together, they will kill each
other. And there are differences in the amount of
aggressiveness that we observe in octopuses. Some
are so aggressive that we've never even seen the
males of the species because basically when
they mate, they leave their hectocotylus arm,
which is their reproductive arm in the mantle
of the female and eject it and escape so that
they don't get eaten. So we've only ever found
their hectocotylus arm. That's how aggressive
that species is. Other species of octopus aren't
quite so aggressive, but they're still asocial.
And it was interesting because the species of
octopus that does that hunting behavior is the
only known social species of octopus.
And so it seems like an interesting
opportunity to test these ideas about what are
the selection pressures that make theory of mind
develop across evolution and what are the
species specific advantages to having a
theory of mind? But it's interesting also because
even though the larger Pacific stripe octopus,
which is the octopus that does that hunting
behavior is social, it's not using this
behavior in a social context, it's using it in a
hunting context. Which suggests that maybe theory
of mind originated from a hunting behavior
where you can imagine it would be useful
for the animal to be able to anticipate where
its food might hide, if it was being chased,
because octopuses eat shrimp and
fish and they're excellent hunters.
And so the idea is that, well,
maybe these ideas that social
behaviors are what drive the evolution of theory
of mind is not quite right and that it emerged
by something earlier like hunting behavior.
Tim Ferriss: It strikes me, as a hunter myself,
which really only was adult onset hunting in
my thirties when I was writing about food,
I felt sort of obligated to explore these things,
that you would observe behaviors that you could
map to theory of mind in thousands of species that
are really effective hunters. And I would love to
bring up three words that are in your intro, which
I had read earlier that people may not associate
with the conversation around psychedelics
currently: autism, stroke, and allergies.
Where did your interest in autism begin?
Dr. Gül Dölen: For me, autism was something that
I became interested in when I was an undergrad
thinking about these problems of theory of mind
and consciousness because I was intrigued by
the possibility that autism could be thought
of as an impairment in theory of mind, and that it
would be sort of a case example of what happens to
your ability to have a fully conscious experience
in the absence of or under conditions of impaired
theory of mind. And so how that relates to
psychedelics is really a long-ish winding story,
which is that when I was a graduate student,
my PhD work was focused on trying to find a
therapy for autism. And we had focused in on
one specific type of autism called Fragile
X. It's the first identified cause of autism.
It's currently the most abundant or the most
common cause of autism is a mutation in
the FMR1 gene, which encodes Fragile X.
And what we had found is that we could do a
biochemical manipulation to correct a cellular
imbalance that in mice corrected many of the
symptoms of autism that we could measure at the
time. And so that was really exciting. Something
like 26 other labs followed up on that work and
several big pharmaceutical companies said, "Okay,
this is it. This is the mechanism based therapy
that we've been looking for." And ran several
very large-scale human clinical trials for that
metabotropic glutamate receptor modulator that we
thought would correct the imbalance in Fragile X.
And when they did those studies, everybody was
hugely disappointed because we were expecting
the drugs to work and to cure the disease. And
we really got very little evidence to support
that view. And I think at the time all the people
who were doing human research and clinical trials
were just willing to throw their hands up and say,
"Well, see, we told you a mouse is not a human.
And that's why the trials didn't work because all
of the human trials were based on mouse studies
and this was just where we went wrong." But a
few of us took a more circumspect view and said,
"Well, yeah, okay, mice aren't humans.
But there were a lot of other differences
between the human trials and the mouse trials."
And to me, the one that really stands out is that
while all of the mouse studies that were done,
the clinical intervention, the alteration of
the receptor were given either right at birth or
at genesis or very early in development. Whereas
all of the human trials, the drugs were given
to adults. And it occurred to me that because
of the timing of when the therapies were given,
all of the mouse studies would've been trying to
correct the underlying biochemical imbalance when
the animal's critical periods were all still open.
Whereas in the human trials, the relevant
critical periods would've been closed by the
time we gave the intervention. And so the
way that I'm imagining that a psychedelic
might be useful in the case of autism is not
to cure the primary underlying problems with
social behaviors directly with psychedelics, but
rather to pair the psychedelic intervention with
the intervention that we think is restoring
the biochemical balance. And when we do that,
we feel like we can restore the biochemical
imbalance while reopening the relevant critical
period so that the patient can learn from their
social environment in the normal way under the
conditions of the restored biochemical imbalance.
Tim Ferriss: So I want to eventually ask you what
reopening the critical period looks like,
chemically or anatomically. But before we
get to that, I would love for you to help me
separate fact from fiction with autism. It's
not a condition that I know much about and
I am nonetheless exposed to many opinions
about autism. And people say for instance, that
the prevalence is skyrocketing, that it may be
caused by people having children when they're
older or it's caused by God knows what, BPA,
you name it. There's probably a million different
theories out there. And I would be curious to know
as a scientist, what appears to be most plausible
as causes of autism? Are rates increasing or are
we just getting better at diagnosing or looking
for that diagnosis, et cetera? Could you just
help give us the ABCs of fact versus fiction?
Dr. Gül Dölen: This is a great question and
one that I'm only going to be able to
give you a partial answer for because
things are changing rapidly around this. So when
I first started studying autism 20 years ago,
it was very narrowly defined as a disease.
There was only five or six different genes
that had been implicated in causing autism.
It was incredibly highly inherited. So if we
can give a heritability score for different
diseases and different inheritance patterns,
hair color and eye color might give you a
heritability score of one. Whereas something
like cervical cancer, which is caused by a virus,
has a heritability score of closer to zero. And
autism had a heritability score of something
like 0.96. So very, very highly heritable.
And it made it different from almost all of the
other neuropsychiatric diseases out there because
things like depression and anxiety are hovering
more around the 0.5 range. So sometimes inherited,
sometimes environmental, usually a
combination of those factors. And at
the time that diagnosis was so narrowly defined
that you got this high heritability. And then
for a variety of different reasons, some of
them scientific, some of them socioeconomic,
the definition of autism got expanded. In
the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of
Neuropsychiatric Disease, the expanded definition
started including the spectrum of autism.
Now rather than having — you absolutely have to
have an impairment in social behaviors and an
impairment in locomotor, stereotypies and all
of these other developmental criteria. It got
expanded and a lot more things started
being included. And when this happened,
the heritability estimates of the disease
dropped. And so my interpretation of those
data is that basically we stopped defining
a disease that was a unified single disease
and started including a lot more things that were
not what I would consider to be classical autism.
Now it feels like to me that this has gotten so
expansive that were essentially including things
like ADHD with social anxiety or all kinds of
other things that while they might be in the realm
of autism, it makes it much harder to identify it
and say, "This is what's being caused." And as a
scientist, I find this to be something that makes
my life much more difficult if we are no longer
defining the disease in a very narrow way. So
when this happens, it's a little bit frustrating.
And so I have tended to focus on those early
identified genes like FMR1, which have been
known to be a cause of autism for a long time.
And more importantly, when we look at all of the
other genes that have been implicated in autism,
so now we're somewhere in the approximately,
a thousand genes have been implicated in autism.
FMR1 seems to be a node. So in other words,
the protein that FMR1 encodes regulates roughly
25 percent of all the other autism genes.
And so to me, that's a good place to start to try
and understand autism. And then I will leave it
up to the epidemiologists to sort out how to
redefine the category so that we're capturing
the right subset of patients and excluding
the subset that are not going to respond to
therapy if we're targeting the subset
that are defined in one specific way.
Tim Ferriss: If we look at FMR1 just as a node
in a focal point, and I apologize that I don't
know the answer to this in advance, but does
that mean that in the same way that if, say,
a couple were planning on having children or
someone were looking at say, surrogacy, you
could do genetic screening? That it's possible for
people to currently do genetic screening for the
probability of autism as an outcome in offspring?
Dr. Gül Dölen: I believe, I mean, it's been a
long time since I was in medical school,
but last time I was, I looked into that. I
believe it was still the case that FMR1 was
rare enough that it wasn't worth it to do the
screening test to try and find it because
you have to balance doing a screening test
against the possibility that the test itself
is going to cause problems with the pregnancy.
So there is a sort of a judgment call there and
unless you had a family history of Fragile X,
I think that it's still the case that people
don't actually test for it beforehand. It's
not like Down syndrome also, where there's any
strong indication that — in Down syndrome there
is a correlation between the age of the
mother and the likelihood of getting Down
syndrome. For schizophrenia, there seems
to be a correlation between the age of the
father and getting schizophrenia.
But for autism, as far as I know,
there is no age-dependent correlation with
your likelihood of getting it. And all of
the causes of autism are each individually
so rare that there's no screening test that
is generally applicable that would be worth doing.
Tim Ferriss: Let's just revisit, as promised,
the reopening of the critical period.
Dr. Gül Dölen: The idea of critical
periods first came in 1935 by Konrad Lorenz, who
was a ethologist, who was studying imprinting
behavior in snow geese. So this is the behavior
that shortly after hatching, the animals will
form a long lasting attachment typically to
their mother. But if the mother isn't around
and instead it's sort of a motorized airplane, or
the scientist in that case, Konrad Lorenz himself,
then they'll form that attachment to that other
moving object in their vicinity. And there are
all these funny pictures online of Konrad
Lorenz being followed around by little snow
geese because they formed this attachment.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, what are snow geese?
Dr. Gül Dölen: They're just a type of geese.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, there we go. Yeah,
just wanted to figure out. Sounds like a
little Scandinavian dwarf or something.
All right, got it. Just a type of geese.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Type of geese, bird. So they
followed around by these birds. They're really
cute pictures. Anyway on this imprinting behavior
though, if you wait, so if you wait until 48
hours after hatching, then they don't form this
behavior. So this attachment that is only possible
within the first 48 hours of hatching and Konrad
Lorenz called that period of time when the animals
are extremely sensitive to their environment and
conformed these long-lasting memories, he called
that window of time the critical period. And
critical periods since then have been described
for so many different things. So probably the
one that most people will be familiar with is
the critical period for language learning. It's
so much easier to learn your first language
that you learn as a child than if you later
on try and pick up another language. It's
harder. You always have an accent. It's not
easy to incorporate that into your first language.
And so that's a critical period for language. And
what my lab did is that we knew from the human
literature that there was probably a critical
period for social learning because we know, for
example, that teenagers are much more susceptible
to peer pressure than adults are. We know that
they prioritize learning from their environment,
from their social interactions much more so than
adults do. And that whatever social environment
you grew up in is sort of your native social
environment. So that, for example, when I go
to Japan, I always feel like a bear in a China
closet because I feel like I'm always insulting
somebody without really realizing it. Because I
didn't grow up in that social environment. And
so I don't know that it's extremely rude to hand
somebody something with one hand instead of two.
These are the kinds of rules that I didn't grow
up exposed to. So it's a foreign social language
to me. So we had this intuition that there was
a critical period for social reward learning,
and that's what my lab discovered. We discovered
that in mice, just like in humans, there is this
window of time where the animals are learning from
their social environment much more strongly than
when they are as adults. And we figured out a
bunch of different mechanisms relating to that
critical periods. Typically, the long, long
arc trying to understand critical periods has
really been focused around this idea that critical
periods are great, but the fact that they close
means that it's really, really hard to treat brain
disorders in adults because the brain is no longer
flexible and able to learn from its environment
in the same way as it was as a child. And so if we
can understand the mechanisms, maybe we can figure
out ways to reopen them for therapeutic benefit.
That's been the goal of neuroscience for the
last hundred years or so, is to try and find
that. And three Nobel prizes have been given for
mechanisms trying to figure this out because it's
understood that this would be so important. But
I've got to say, when I was a graduate student,
this idea of finding the master key for unlocking
critical periods, I never believed in it. And
in fact, my lab and another lab at Harvard
were kind of in an intellectual debate with
one another over this idea of, "Can there
be a master key?" And I was always like,
"No. Obviously anything that could do that to
the brain would either cause massive amnesia,
would cause seizures, and possibly could cause
the whole brain to melt." And I was like,
"There's no master key. Stop it. Forget
about it, Harvard, you're just wrong." Okay?
And so what we've come up with now is
we started with the idea that, well,
MDMA is different from other psychedelics in that
it has this very prominent pro-social component
to it. People take MDMA and they want to cuddle,
they want to be sociable. Some people talk about
this incredible feeling of empathy and being
able to see other people's pain. It's just a
very pro-social type of psychedelic. In fact, some
people even want to call it an empathogen rather
than a straight up psychedelic. And so we started
with that idea that, "Okay, we're trying to reopen
a social critical period. We know it follows a
lot of the same rules as other critical periods,
but maybe MDMA is the way to do it." And in fact,
we did find evidence that MDMA reopens the social
critical period, and it does so by restoring
oxytocin metaplasticity in the nucleus succumbs.
And we loved this idea that that was the story
and whatever. Psychedelics, other psychedelics
probably wouldn't do it. That was our original
idea. But then again, mother nature, tricky.
So when we did the control experiments to
look at what other psychedelics are doing,
we found that all of the psychedelics reopened
this critical period, even though nobody is
taking LSD and doing a 60-person cuddle puddle.
Not that I've seen anyway, right? But LSD is not
prominently a pro-social type of psychedelic.
Neither is ibogaine, neither is ketamine. And yet
all of them are reopening this critical
period for social reward learning. And
so what this suggested to me immediately
was is that the whole social part of the
MDMA story is a little bit of a red herring.
Really what psychedelics are are this master
key for unlocking critical periods.
There's not just one critical period,
there are lots of different critical periods.
But we are beginning to get a sense that many of
the critical periods close using the same sort of
governing principle, the same kind of molecules,
if not the exact same molecules, will or
have been implicated in the closure of,
say, the visual critical period or the touch
critical period or the motor critical period.
What's different is that the social critical
period is different from those in that it's
not a sensory motor. It's an emotional critical
period that we think is encoded in a different
part of the brain, the nucleus accumbens,
which is part of the limbic system. It's a
different type of brain region than the classical
critical periods which have all been defined
in the cortex. So we don't know, still don't
know, whether or not the rules are the same.
But what we did know, what we did
figure out is that when we did
RNA sequencing or genetic profiling,
transcriptional profiling, of what happens to
this brain region when we give psychedelics and we
reopen this social critical period, the molecules
that get up and down regulated in response to
psychedelics, but not cocaine, share a lot of
overlap in terms of their molecular identity
with the molecules that have been implicated in
the closure of other types of critical
periods like vision, somatic sensation, motor.
So beginning to see lots of circumstantial
evidence that the psychedelics are all doing
the same thing, they're reopening this
critical period, and they're doing it in
a way that suggests that the social critical
period, the social part of it is irrelevant,
and that this is really tapping into molecular
mechanisms that are conserved across all the
different types of critical periods.
If that's true, then it suggests
that these drugs might be useful for
reopening all kinds of critical periods,
including the visual critical periods, including
the touch critical periods, including the motor
critical periods. That's the next direction
that the lab is heading, is testing the idea
that psychedelics are in fact this master key
for unlocking lots of different critical periods.
Tim Ferriss: Question back to autism. And, man,
must you get a lot of questions about autism,
so my apologies. But I want to use that
example because — this will underscore
my ignorance in so many of these topics. But if
we're looking at a narrow definition of autism,
so we're not succumbing to the scope creep
in DSM or elsewhere where suddenly everything
and its cousin is autism, but focusing more
on the Fragile X and that type of narrower,
more specific definition, when I then think
of a critical window, what is the interplay of
the genetics and the critical window when it is
untreated, when you don't have an intervention?
Does that mean that there is a critical window
but it's narrower, or for whatever reason
the child is less adaptive in that critical
window? So it's not genetic determinism. It's
not like if you have this particular phenotype
you're destined to get autism and that you can
unwind the clock or rewind the clock in a sense
with potentially something like psychedelics
to give them a second shot on goal. I know I'm
asking this in probably a very clumsy way because
I don't understand exactly why it would work,
but why would reopening the window help someone
potentially with autism if they weren't able to
capitalize on a similar window earlier themselves?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Autism is a little bit complicated
because it's a multifactorial disease. Let me just
give a different example to help clarify
and maybe make it clearer what we think is
the way that psychedelic could be used for
autism. And that's with vision. One of the
early observations of critical periods is that if
a child is born with bilateral cataracts and then
you remove those cataracts and they can see, but
if you wait and you don't remove those cataracts
until they're age six or seven, then even though
the physical impediment to vision is gone,
the brain cannot adjust to the visual inputs
anymore, and so the child remains blind forever.
That's because there is a critical period
for setting the strength of the synapses
for visual inputs. Once that critical
period is closed, even though the primary
impediment or the primary injury has been
resolved, the brain can't — it missed its
opportunity to wire properly for the visual
environment and so they'll be blind forever.
The idea there is, if you missed the window and
the child didn't have their cataracts removed
until they were seven or eight years old and you
paired cataract removal surgery with psychedelics,
then the idea would be that — if psychedelics
can reopen visual critical periods, then the
idea would be that you would be able to restore
vision because you would be pairing the primary
intervention, which is the cataract removal
surgery, with the reopening of the critical
period to give the opportunity to learn from
the visual environment in the natural way.
With autism, it's the same idea. We're saying,
"Okay, there's a genetic impairment that causes
autism which we think is related to an imbalance
at this one specific receptor, which we can
correct by targeting that receptor. But if we just
do that alone after the social critical period has
closed, then they still remain socially blind,
if you will, because we missed that window." So
the idea is if we could pair that mGluR therapy
with a psychedelic, then we could restore the
imbalance and also restore the ability to learn
from the social environment so that they can,
under those corrected conditions, have a shot at
learning the ways of social interaction the way
they would've during natural development.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Thank
you. That's very helpful.
I want to just perhaps mention that — and this
is actually from The Microdose, which is a great
newsletter. You were featured in The Microdose
from UC Berkeley not too long ago. Some people
listening may wonder why we shouldn't always
leave our critical windows open. Wouldn't that be
great? We could learn everything and anything. I
just want to read something here and then we
can move on, although we could expand on it.
When you talk to people who are on
psychedelics, it's like herding kittens.
They're paying attention to everything. "Look
at this leaf," "My shoe won't fit," et cetera.
You're in full explorer mode, which is wonderful,
but it's not very efficient. Habits get a bad rap,
but you couldn't get out the door if you didn't
have them. Living in a world where you're trying
to learn and pay attention to everything
is emotionally and energetically costly.
We could certainly expand on
this, but needless to say,
there is a lot to be said for a stable version of
reality with certain scripts that run reliably. Is
there anything you would like to add to that?
Dr. Gül Dölen: I would just expand on that a
little bit by pointing out that the reason
that we have critical periods at all,
rather than being genetically encoded with
everything that we need to survive in the world,
is because the world is big and varied.
If you genetically encoded everything,
you probably would be very limited in how you
could navigate that world. My parents are Turkish.
If I was genetically encoded with Turkish,
the fact that I grew up in the United States,
it would make my life very difficult because I
wouldn't speak English, I would speak Turkish.
But because I have a language critical period,
what's genetically encoded is the ability to learn
a language, not the language itself. That ability
to learn from our environment is why we have
them. But as everybody knows, being a teenager
sucks. It's hard. It's painful. It's really very
emotionally draining to constantly be checking
yourself, trying to figure out how you fit in.
Sometimes, you want to just get on with it, and
if the environment that you're in is stable, then
you don't need to necessarily be adapting
or adjusting your model of the world every
single move that you make. That's why
we think that critical periods close.
But then another question is, well, why does
the brain have a sort of readymade mechanism
that psychedelics can tap into for reopening
critical periods? Why can we reopen them so
easily if the brain wasn't already built to
do this? This is really me speculating, but I
suspect it's because when we have these habits,
they're adaptive so long as the environment is
stable. But then there's a radical shift in the
environment, then you can imagine that it would
be adaptive to be able to reopen critical
periods and relearn from your environment.
Going back to the language example, as long as
everybody around you speaks English, it's probably
not all that adaptive to be learning Spanish.
But if you move to Spain or you move to Central
America, then suddenly nobody's speaking English,
and you want to be able to learn the language
that everybody's speaking around you. So we have a
little bit of other evidence that this deprivation
technique of reopening critical periods, which has
been described for things like the visual system,
the sensory system, a little bit in the
motor system, there's evidence for this,
that this deprivation induced can also
reopen our social critical period.
Here's another rule that applies across critical
periods, is that deprivation is a technique.
This might be the explanation, for example,
for why it's easier to learn Spanish if you
go to Guatemala than if you go to Costa Rica,
because in Costa Rica everybody speaks Spanish,
but everybody also speaks English. So it's
very hard. You're not deprived of English,
you're just exposed to Spanish. Whereas in
Guatemala, almost nobody speaks English and
so you're deprived and you get the language.
That's one idea that we have. We haven't
proven it. But the other part of that
is that it's interesting to note that,
historically, religious practices across many,
many different cultures have used deprivation
techniques to get to that mystical state
that people talk about. Zen Buddhist call
it beginner's mind. If you were looking for a
neurobiological description of beginner's mind,
reopening critical periods would be it.
So what we think, possibly, is that — remember
how I said that I was as an undergrad, I was
really interested in getting around to using
neuroscience to answer the really big questions
that philosophers seem to have exclusive domain
for? Well, this might be it, right? It might be
that if what it feels like to be in that altered
state of consciousness or that mystical experience
that we think of with psychedelics is just what
it feels like to reopen critical periods.
Then this explanation, this critical period
explanation, gives us a mechanistic handle
to start answering those big questions like,
well, what is consciousness? Well, what is
that mystical experience? What does it mean
to feel you're an altered state?
Tim Ferriss: In the course of
my reading, and feel free to correct anything
that I misstate here, but part of what makes
catalyzing pro-social behavior
in octopuses is so interesting
with the use of, say, MDMA is that the nervous
system of an octopus and the anatomical structure,
sorry, as compared to humans are so different.
So in humans we might attribute some of the
outcomes that we see or therapeutic effects to,
I believe the nucleus accumbens. But then you
look at an octopus, no accumbens, no amygdala,
no default mode network, no prefrontal cortex.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What have you gleaned from the
octopus work as it relates to critical periods
and or interesting characteristics of MDMA?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Tim, I'm really glad that you asked
that question because I think that possibly a lot
of people in your audience know a little something
about psychedelics and they've seen the studies
where people have been given psychedelics and they
take an fMRI image and they point to this brain
region or that brain region and say, "Aha, this is
where psychedelics are working." And they get this
sort of warm and fuzzy feeling like, "I understand
now what's happening." And as a neuroscientist,
I am susceptible to that interpretation as
well. I don't do it with fMRI. I do it with
circuit mapping and viral mediated gene
transfer and look at it at a much higher
resolution than fMRI imaging allows, so my lab,
we do whole-cell patch clamp electrophysiology,
so we can do single neuron resolution of these
kinds of anatomical maps of what neurons are
getting turned on by psychedelics.
And from those types of analyses,
we get this satisfying feeling like, "Aha, MDMA
is causing the nucleus accumbens neurons to light
up. It's causing the oxytocin neurons and the
hypothalamus to fire and release oxytocin. We
got it. We understand how these work." And I
think the really, really compelling thing about
the octopus study and why so many people who
are not lay people, just regular scientists,
we're a little bit shaken by this octopus paper,
is because it challenges that very comfortable
place that we've all been sitting with circuit
mapping that we have an answer. And what it says
instead is that, yeah, okay, those anatomical
results matter and they're telling us something,
but they're not telling us the general rules
of how you build complex behavioral functions
from synapses, circuits, brain regions.
And instead what they're telling us is
something like the historical accident or the
evolutionary byproduct of one animal's history
of how they came up with this solution. But we
haven't really learned anything about what are
the generalizable principles? What are the motifs?
What are the rules governing those circuit level
rearrangements that enable complex behavior?
Tim Ferriss: What are some other ideas in your
mind that need challenging or that could be
challenged, just writ large in psychedelics
or psychedelic-related science?
Dr. Gül Dölen: I think the two big
ones that I have, let me start with — since we're
already beating up on the people who do human
research a little bit, let me just challenge the
idea that we can only understand what psychedelics
are doing in humans. That I think for the
last decade and the early part of this one,
there has been this idea that really the cool
and interesting part of psychedelics, you can
only understand by studying it in humans, because
humans are the only ones who do the behaviorally
complex enough things that you would want to know
about what psychedelics are doing. And I consider
Alexander Shulgin to be an elder in this field for
me. I met him when he came to visit MIT. I have
this goofy picture of myself as this young little
neuroscientist, all enamored of Alexander Shulgin.
And I think he was very much a proponent of this
view that he needed to take the psychedelics
himself because really, the interesting part of
what psychedelics are doing, you can only know on
a personal level. And I want to push back against
that idea because I think that as we start to get
a better handle of what they're actually doing in
mice, we may be able to come up with things that
generalize. Because after all, humans didn't just
emerge out of nowhere. We weren't plopped here on
earth by aliens. We evolved just all other
animals on Earth. And so we were subject to
a lot of the same rules and we came up with some
mostly overlapping solutions and some unique ones.
And so I think we will eventually get to a point
where we can study the really cool and interesting
parts of what psychedelics are doing in animals as
well as in humans. And I think that our critical
period idea is one step in that direction.
I think that many people in your audience
may have also heard of the idea that
psychedelics are inducing plasticity.
And I'm very careful not to use that word if I
can avoid it, because plasticity is a word that
is thrown around a lot and it means a lot of
different things to a lot of different people.
So for a synaptic neurophysiologist, it has a very
specific meaning. It's about the something that
you can record from doing whole-cell recordings
or patch-clamp recordings or even unit recordings
in the brain. But it's an electrophysiological
property that is defined between two synapses.
Whereas the clinicians basically use plasticity
to mean anything that changes over time,
which is so general, it sort of loses meaning.
And so I try not to use that word as much as
possible, and especially in the context of
psychedelics, because some people have tried
to make the argument that what psychedelics
are so-called psychoplastogens or drugs that
induce plasticity. And this is an inaccurate and
confusing terminology that I would really hope
we could abandon because there are drugs that
cause plasticity in the way that word implies.
And they're all drugs of abuse. So heroin,
nicotine, cocaine, amphetamine, these are all
psychoactive drugs that cause robust bidirectional
plasticity. They cause the neurons to sprout,
they cause the neurons to shrink, they cause
robust changes. And it's that very plastic
or hyperplastic property that we think underlies
their addictive potential because that exaggerated
sprouting or that exaggerated plasticity,
we think is what enables drugs of abuse to
override the breaks on learning and memory
that are normally part of naturally rewarding
stimuli that allow memories to be
encoded in a way that are driven by
limitations on association.
So let me give you an example
because I'm fumbling a little. So the example I
like to give is that a natural reward, like food,
for example. We like food. And if I like a, let's
say, a turkey sandwich, I might remember the
memory that I formed to a turkey sandwich that
I just ate and loved would be something like,
"Oh, I love that turkey sandwich. Next time I'm
hungry and I'm in this neighborhood, then I'm
going to go to that store and buy that sandwich
again. I loved it." But for drugs of abuse,
we override those associative constraints on
when we want the thing. And a drug of abuse,
cocaine or nicotine, it doesn't matter if you're
hungry or you're in the right neighborhood or
it's not out of your way. You just like it always.
And that very ability to override that constraint
is what we think the hyperplasticity is encoding
and enabling and making those drugs so much more
addictive. And so I wouldn't want people
to confuse that property, that hyperplastic
property with what we think is actually happening
with psychedelics, which is that psychedelics,
we believe, and there's starting to be
other evidence to support this view,
are enabling what's called metaplasticity.
Which I know that it's confusing terminology,
hyperplasticity versus metaplasticity. But
metaplasticity is an idea that's been around
for over 20 years now that says that the ability
to induce plasticity also can change over time,
typically. So when you're young, your ability
to induce plasticity is greater than when you're
older. The ability to induce plasticity declines
and there are molecular things that control that.
Tim Ferriss: You were mentioning that
plasticity can mean a lot of different
things to different people. So in this
case, the ability to induce plasticity,
what does plasticity mean to you in this use?
Dr. Gül Dölen: So the metaplastic definition,
I mean it's a very specific definition, plasticity
of plasticity, and in that case it was defined by
Mark Bear and Cliff Abraham, and it was a synaptic
physiology. So it's synaptic plasticity. The
change in response of stimulating one synapse and
the magnitude of the response changing when you're
recording the post synapse.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Dr. Gül Dölen: So very narrowly defined again.
Metaplasticity originally was used to define
what happens in the reopening or the closure
of the critical period for ocular dominance
plasticity. And it was defined primarily in terms
of the change in the subunit composition of the
NMDA receptor, which is one of the receptors
that's been so heavily implicated in learning
in memory and specifically also learning in
memory with regards to visual processing.
Tim Ferriss: Does that mean that ketamine
would have any particular applications to
studies involving visual processing? I'm just
thinking given the — seems like there's the
decent effect at the NMDA receptor level with
ketamine, when you look at chronic pain and
other things. Is that the case or is not so much?
Dr. Gül Dölen: I mean, yes, almost certainly.
Almost certainly the NMDA receptors, there are
a variety of things that have been attributed
to the NMDA receptor. For a long time it
was my favorite receptor, and here's why.
I know it's super nerdy to
have a favorite receptor, but —
Tim Ferriss: No. I'm into it. I'm into it.
Dr. Gül Dölen: So NMDA receptors are
fast neurotransmitter receptors, but they're
different from AMPA receptors, which are
the other major subtype of glutamate receptor
because they have something that basically the
way the receptor is designed is that it's blocked
usually by magnesium. And only when the neuron is
active or the membrane potential changes and
the magnesium no longer wants to sit in there,
that magnesium comes out. So because of that
property, the NMDA receptor is thought to be
a natural coincidence detector. So it can detect
when two neurons are firing at the same time. And
that has gotten neuroscientists super excited
about the idea that this is exactly the type of
coincidence detection that would be necessary at
a cellular level in order to encode memories. And
this idea has been around for a while now. It's
why people are excited about the NMDA receptor.
Incidentally, it's also thought to be why ketamine
and PCP interfere with memory. So they do cause
impairments in memory because they mess with a
receptor that we think is super important for
encoding memories. Now, in terms of this critical
period idea, NMDA receptors, they come in, they're
made up of different subunits, and the composition
of those subunits changes over development. So
very early in development, the NMDA receptors have
the subunit, the B subunit is more predominant.
And the way I remember that is that that's the
NR2B subunit is for baby, and then the A subunit
is for adults. So as the brain matures, then the
subunit switches out and it goes from being 2B
heavy to being 2A heavy. And what that does to
the receptor is it makes it more or less likely
to be able to induce that synaptic plasticity
when the glutamate binds to that receptor.
And that is the original first classical
understanding of what a metaplastic change
would look like. It would be the change in the
subunit composition of the NMDA receptor that
enabled the baby receptors to induce plasticity
more readily than the adult receptors do.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. And just to try to recap
my understanding, which will hopefully help
the audience track as well. Jumping back to
the autism example and the Fragile X or FMR1,
the joint therapy would look like using the
compounds such as, possibly a psychedelic,
to increase the metaplasticity followed by, or
maybe simultaneous, with the administration of the
drug that was so disappointing in human trials
because it was administered to adults who had
already switched to a different dominant subtype.
I'm getting close, I'm not quite there, but —
Dr. Gül Dölen: You're very close and you're
actually picking up on something that is a
hesitation I have about using psychedelics in
autism. So there's another, a third type of
glutamate receptor that I love. It's called the
metabotropic glutamate receptor, the mGluR and
the metabotropic glutamate receptor, we think is
the one whose signaling is so altered in Fragile
X. And the metabotropic glutamate receptors are
also implicated in — as their brain matures, their
expression goes down. And so we think that that
coincides with the closure of the critical period.
And what we think is that in Fragile X, that mGluR
signaling is exaggerated. It's not being curtailed
in the right way. And so we have some evidence to
suggest that autism might be caused by a failure
to properly close the critical periods. So even
though theoretically I like the idea of combining
negative allosteric modulator of the mGluR with
a psychedelic that can reopen, say the social
critical periods through metaplasticity
in this case of a different receptor,
I think in this case it would be the oxytocin
receptor that would be the relevant one.
I am a little bit hesitant to jump into human
trials for that without first testing the safety
of this in mouse models because again, there's
this tension between, there's some idea that
the pathogenesis of the disease is related to a
failure to close the critical periods properly.
So I'm not sure that reopening them later is
going to be necessarily the right way to go.
So it's still a hypothesis that we're testing.
Tim Ferriss: How do allergies fit into this?
I've become very, very interested
in allergies and all sorts of —
not to paint with too broad a brush, but sort of
autoimmune questions specifically as related to
psychedelic compounds. How do allergies fit in?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Well, first I should premise this
by telling you that my mom is an immunologist
and she hates this idea. So she and I we
spar over this and we have a very different view
of the relationship between the immune system
and the nervous system. She basically lives
in an immune centric world where the nervous
system is just like an downstream effector of the
immune system, which is the primary controller of
everything. And obviously I think it's the other
way around. So the idea with allergy is this,
there is some epidemiological evidence to suggest
that allergy has a higher prevalence in countries
where the food and the water is largely parasite
free. And so that part of the immune system,
which is ordinarily used to fight off parasitic
infections, is left jobless. So the idea is that
in that state of joblessness, it sort of goes
out looking for another threat to fight against,
to protect the body against. And in this
formulation, I am thinking how that threat
gets assigned is really through the brain.
The brain is saying, "Okay, well that dog
is barking at you and your immune system is
left jobless, that's threatening. Go fight
against the dog proteins." And if that's true,
at least in a subset of patients with allergy,
then you can imagine that reopening that
learned sort of threat, that critical period
for the learned threat of that's mis-assigned,
would enable people to unlearn the association
between dog and allergy. Now that's a very
different way, for example, of looking at it than
the way that some people focus on psychedelics to
think of it as they have these anti-inflammatory
properties, which I think are true independent
of this critical period explanation and
that property might be beneficial in allergy,
independent of this learned association
framework that I'm proposing around the
critical period. So we just don't know yet.
I like the idea though, because there are
a few anecdotal stories of, I think Andrew
Weil has a story where he tears himself up.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to bring him up.
Cats. Yeah.
Dr. Gül Dölen: And I mean, I love the idea because
I actually kind of wanted to be a veterinarian,
but I'm allergic to horses, dogs, and cats. So I
would love to take psychedelics and cure myself
of those allergies. And while I love this idea,
I don't believe it enough yet to take a bunch of
psychedelics and go snuggle up to a horse because
I think we could be looking at anaphylactic shock
in that situation. So I don't believe it yet, but
I like the idea as something that we could test.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, I'm glad you brought up
Andy and not the sole example. I mean I have an
understanding the plural of anecdote is not data,
but nonetheless sometimes helpful for generating
hypotheses. This is something that's been in the
conversation with numerous anecdotes for a
while. And I guess what I want to ask next
is whether it's autism, stroke, or allergies?
And I do want to come back to stroke. When we
are talking about reopening critical windows,
and in the introduction in your bio that I read,
we had MDMA, LSD, psilocybin, ketamine, and
ibogaine, which act on quite a number of
different receptors. LSD seems particularly
promiscuous, maybe ibogaine as well. But
broadly speaking, are we talking about increasing
post-synaptic sensitivity? In which case they
could be hitting different receptors, but as long
as it's eliciting that type of sensitivity that is
associated with earlier critical window, it fits
the description of reopening the critical window.
Dr. Gül Dölen: So let me back up for a second and
just explain that I think there's a debate going
on in the field right now because if you look
back in the textbooks written in the '70s and '80s
about psychedelics, textbooks written by people
like Solomon Snyder, who started my department
at Johns Hopkins and discovered almost every
neurotransmitter receptor you've ever heard of,
including, by the way, the serotonin 2A receptor.
Their definition of what a psychedelic is was
very broad. So they basically said it's anything
that causes this altered state of consciousness,
altered perception of time, space, body, self,
these were all sort of things that psychedelics
do. And they included psychedelics ranging from
ketamine, PCP, all of what people are now trying
to call the classical serotonin psychedelics
like LSD, mescaline, psilocybin, DMT, and then
also the weird ones like MDMA and ibogaine.
And both Snyder and Alexander Shulgin consider
all of those drugs to be psychedelics. More
recently, there has been this push mostly led by
the chemists to say, "Oh, no, no, no. If we look
at the receptor binding properties of these drugs,
the classical psychedelics, the hallucinogenic
psychedelics, they're all serotonin 2A receptor
binding. And even though they're promiscuous, even
though they're binding to a bunch of different
receptors, the psychedelic effects seem to be
mediated by this receptor using pharmacology
studies in humans." And they are really pushing
hard to exclude MDMA and ibogaine and ketamine
from the definition of classical psychedelics.
But I personally feel that this is putting the
cart before the horse because we don't know
that that is necessarily a good boundary for
defining psychedelics. First of all, because
we know that most of the psychedelics
are very promiscuous in their binding.
Second of all, we don't really understand
whether or not the 2A receptor is required for the
therapeutic properties. So there is some evidence
that there are anti-depressant properties that
may or may not be blocked by serotonin receptor
antagonists. There's two papers that have exactly
opposite results about this right now. I am not
entirely convinced that those antidepressant
properties that they're measuring have anything
to do with the durable context dependent long-term
therapeutic effects of psychedelics that we see in
humans. And so I think it's up for debate whether
or not the serotonin 2A receptor is required. But
what we do know is that psychedelics that have
primary binding at NMDA receptors, serotonin
transporters, serotonin 2A receptors, kappa-opioid
receptors, ones that span the diversity of
receptors all show some therapeutic effect.
And so our lab has really been focused in
trying to understand, "Well, what's
the commonality across all of those
receptors?" And so to, in a long-winded
way, get back to your original question,
what we wanted to know is what's downstream of
those receptors that's common to all of those
psychedelics. And we don't have the complete
answer yet, but the answer that we're coming
up upon is that it's not the receptor. It's
not even one step downstream of that. People
have been excited about the possibility that
changes in biochemical signaling at the level
of beta-arrestin might be the next step after the
receptor that might be common. We don't see that
to be the case in our studies. And what it seems
to be is downstream of that even more, which is
regulation of the extracellular
matrix, which we think is sort of
the final common pathway that happens.
And the working model that we have
is that psychedelics bind to their receptor,
and when they sit in that receptor for too long,
it signals to the cell, "Oh, no.
Oh, no. Excitotoxicity is coming.
Hit the reset button." And what that does through
a variety of different mechanisms is we think,
and we don't have strong evidence to support
this, but this is our working model, is that that,
hit the reset button, involves calling in all
of the receptors, internalizing them, cleaning
up the synapse, degrading the extracellular
matrix that is holding the synapse together.
And the last step of making a synapse mature
and stable. And that hard reset is enabling the
reintegration of those baby receptors that are
more sensitive and able to induce plasticity.
That's sort of our working model.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm curious,
just to revisit kappa-opioid for a second, because
the only kappa-opioid agonist that I'm familiar
with is Salvinorin A. Some people may know
Salvia divinorum, which from a phenomenological
perspective, to get real fancy, subjectively
people find it typically pretty dysphoric. And I'm
just wondering how, perhaps it's not Salvinorin
A, but any kappa-opioid agonist might be used
therapeutically, what applications might exist?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah, I mean, people have been
excited about kappa-opioids because
it's thought to be like, that's going
to be the one that's going to make you not be
addicted to it. And it's not very pleasurable.
Tim Ferriss: That's for sure.
Dr. Gül Dölen: It's not very
pleasurable. Nobody wants to take it. I
don't want to overstep the kappa-opioid
stuff. The reason that we got interested in it
is because the ibogaine also has high affinity
for kappa-opioid receptors, but it also accesses
serotonin transporters. So I really don't know
what the answer is there. I thought the
beta-arrestin story was going to nicely
sew everything up and it just didn't.
Tim Ferriss: So what is beta-arrestin? I'm going
to plead ignorance. I don't know what that is.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Basically most of the psychedelic
drugs, except for ketamine and PCP, are acting at
what are called G-protein coupled receptors. So
when I was talking about NMDA receptors versus
mGluR receptors, the difference is mGluRs are
G-protein coupled receptors. And NMDA receptors
are ion channels, so they're inotropic receptors.
So metabotropic inotropic, it has to do with how
they're coupled to internal signaling. So all of
the G-protein coupled receptors, including almost
all of the serotonin receptors, they work by,
when the drugs binds to their binding pocket,
they induce a series of biochemical events,
either excitatory or inhibitory, biochemical
changes downstream that are sort of the second
messengers, if you will, of the receptor binding.
Now that's just how they normally signal. But
when a drug like LSD binds to the serotonin 2A
receptor, Brian Roth's group has shown that when
it sits in its receptor, it has an unusually
long off rate. So normally when transmitters
get in their receptor, they jump in and
they jump right back out. So they pop in,
pop out really, really fast, less than a second
time scale. LSD, when it sits in the serotonin
2A receptor binding pocket, a little lid comes
down and locks it into place. And when that lid
locks the LSD into place, it's off rate goes to
four and a half hours, which is flicking insane.
Tim Ferriss: It's going to be a long night.
Dr. Gül Dölen: It's going to be a long night.
Exactly. And that's the half off. So only half of
it comes off in four and a half hours. Right? And
so this is a really important insight into
why it is that LSDs effects last so long.
But when it sits in that receptor for too long,
instead of signaling through the normal G-protein
coupled signaling pathway, what happens is
it starts sending signal to the cell. "No,
instead of G-protein, you need to hit a
different biochemical pathway. We need to
trigger beta-arrestin." And beta-arrestin is just
another biochemical pathway that gets triggered by
that receptor being activated too long. And what
is thought that beta-arrestin does is rather than
do the second messenger signaling, it says to
the cell, "Pull that receptor out, we're about
to get toxic damage from too much receptor
activation." So beta-arrestin and signaling
historically has been thought to be a signal
to the cell that says, "Pull in the receptors."
And so I really loved the idea that even though
not all psychedelics bind to the serotonin 2A,
most of them, you could imagine a scenario where
they were triggering beta-arrestin signaling over
G-protein coupled signaling, and that if
you knocked out the beta-arrestin protein,
that you could block the ability of psychedelics
to reopen critical periods. And while that was
true for some of the psychedelics, it turned
out not to be the universal mechanism that
spans across all of the psychedelics. So that
was a little bit of a bummer, I have to say,
because I thought, "All right, we'll solve
it. It'll be done, and I can rest easy."
But it didn't work out that simple. Mother
nature always likes to trip us up like that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, the mother nature curve
ball seems to come more often than not.
I do want to get to strokes and how they fit in.
But before we get there, I have to scratch an itch
because I've been wanting to ask you for a while
now. Excuse me. First, a bit of background. You
mentioned Alexander Shulgin, also known as Sasha
Shulgin. For people who don't recognize the name,
incredibly adept, incredibly prolific biochemist,
very much recommend people check out PiHKAL
and TiHKAL, which he wrote with his wife.
But the contrast you drew earlier was one of,
say, maybe human centricity. So he not only
created or resurrected hundreds, maybe thousands
of different psychedelic compounds, but also was
a very dedicated self-experimenter. The tasting
parties were very famous, of course. Where
do you most strongly perhaps agree or align
with Sasha? What are things that you perhaps
have in common, if anything comes to mind?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah, I've got to tell you a funny
story of when he came to visit MIT when I was
a graduate student. It was the opening party
for the new building. I won't name any names,
but everybody had invited a bunch of Nobel
Prize winners who had discovered every cool
thing in biology. They all got up there and not
necessarily knew anything about neuroscience,
they were all older, and they gave a
little biography and then sat back down.
Then Sasha got up on stage. He was just basically
the same age as everybody else, the only person
without a Nobel Prize on that stage, and yet
he was so alert and so adept. He was like,
"Then we added this methyl group over here and
this happened and the behavioral response. Then
we did this and we got ego this, and we put that
on there." All of the neuroscientists were just
rapt attention because this is it. This is
what we all dream of as neuroscientists,
is to have some manipulation that we can give, in
this case a drug, that is dramatically altering
the way that the brain is functioning
and interpreting the world around it.
And here is this chemist explaining to us how
this could be done just by adding a methyl
group in this position versus that position. We
were all just blown away. I don't think there
was anybody who walked away from that lecture
thinking, gosh, psychedelics should just stay
in the backwaters, we shouldn't care about
this as neuroscience. Obviously not. In fact,
it's how I got excited about neuroscience
to begin with. I took this class when I was
an undergrad called Drugs, Brain, and Behavior.
In that class, the first day I saw the photograph
of the molecule of LSD sitting right next to the
molecule of serotonin and the similarities between
them, I was like, "This is it. This is how we're
going to crack it. This is how we're going to get
at those hard questions of neuroscience because
here are chemicals that can alter our entire
sense of reality, consciousness, perception,
time, self, space, everything." And I am not
alone. I think most neuroscientists who have tried
psychedelics would have exactly the same response.
The difference between me and Sasha really in
terms of our approach is that Sasha comes from
an older tradition in science, which very much
prioritized the do the experiment on yourself
idea. That has a long and glorious tradition
in science. For example, we have a cure for
ulcers because there was a biologist who was
convinced that those were caused by a bacteria,
but nobody believed him. So he drank a vial of
bacteria, gave himself ulcers, and then took a
bunch of antibiotics and cured himself of the
ulcers, and he won the Nobel Prize for that.
The difference is, with psychedelics, is
that that's a little bit trickier to do
because psychedelics have this property, which
William James pointed out over 100 years ago,
of creating this sense of — what he called the
noetic property, this feeling that "Now that
I've had this experience, I know the really
real. The true truth has been revealed to me
and everything before this moment was just a
facade or some lesser truth or some limited
access to the truth. But now I really know."
For a scientist, that's pretty dangerous.
For a scientist, you always want to be able to
have a little bit of skepticism about what it
is that you have discovered; you always want
to keep your ideas as provisional until the
next test comes along. It should always
be a working model, never "This is the 10
commandments of neuroscience." That's not the
way that we do science. So the noetic property,
I think, does mean that that experiment where
you take a bunch of bacteria and give yourself
ulcers is a little bit harder to justify
in this neuroscience now. Let's not lie.
Tim Ferriss: In psychedelics. Yeah.
Hard to be an objective or strive
to be an objective scientist if you turn
yourself into David Koresh accidentally.
So how do strokes fit into this?
Dr. Gül Dölen: For a long time now, clinically,
we have known that right after you have a
stroke, you have this very short window of time,
really, really closed by three months, but really
you want to get in there within six weeks to two
months or so, where physical therapy is going to
have its maximal effect or benefit for helping you
to recover the motor function that you lost
because of the stroke. That window of time,
we don't exactly know why it closes.
But it seems to be that it's not that
the damaged part of the brain suddenly resprouts
neurons, it's that the brain regions immediately
adjacent to the damaged part of the brain become
flexible again and able to perform or control the
motor functions that were lost by the brain region
immediately next to it. That window closes just
like all other critical periods close. So far, the
best way that we have for reopening that critical
period is to give another stroke. But nobody
wants to cure stroke by giving another stroke,
so that's just not a clinically useful way.
Tim Ferriss: Hard to sell. Hard to sell that.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah, definitely hard
to sell. We like the idea that maybe
we could branch out into other critical periods
like this one to see whether or not psychedelics
can reopen that critical period for stroke.
We have a collaboration with Steven Zeiler,
who's a neurologist at Johns Hopkins
who has developed a rodent model for
that critical period of motor recovery following
stroke. He also has a stroke clinic at Hopkins.
We're working closely with them to see whether
or not this idea really can help these patients,
which basically it's a 400,000 patients a year
in the United States who have debilitating,
lasting impairments because of stroke.
It's a huge number of people. I think if
this ends up being true, I think it's — it's super
exciting because here's something that we started
out with, "I'm just curious what MDMA will do
in an octopus." It was totally curiosity-based
science. To see it evolve into something
that can potentially help so many people is,
as a scientist, just super gratifying. It's
pretty rare. Nobody really gets to have those
kinds of woo-hoo success stories. So that's
very gratifying to me on a personal level.
But also, I think that for all of the psychedelics
enthusiasts out there, it's a lesson in how
important it is to never stop learning, never
stop questioning. I think there was an intuition
a few years ago that, well, indigenous people
have been using psychedelics forever, we don't
really need to understand their mechanisms, we
don't really need to dig into how it is these
things work because we know they're going to work
because they've got this long history behind them.
But I think that if this ends up being
true, that this mechanistic explanation
can really open up whole new avenues that
people hadn't been thinking of before,
then I think that that's a testament to
the importance of always keep an open mind,
always look for more answers, more
questions, and keep searching.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. I would also say, even
if, let's just say hypothetically, these various
indigenous cultures have figured it out, let's
just take that as an assumption for a second,
they've figured out how to use these things, but
the scale at which they're used and the context
within which they're used are on the order
of, say, max 100 or several hundred people
within the safety net of certain rituals
and familial and social support structures
that it cannot be replicated at scale in say a
western treatment paradigm. You need new tools,
and that requires exploration and testing.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Let me just riff on that for
a second because I think that that's a really
important point about the context. The context
of disease is also different in this culture
versus other cultures. How a disease is defined
is different across cultures and how you might
approach a disease is defined differently across
cultures. A good example is the way that ibogaine
is used traditionally. These cultures using
ibogaine for traditional healing practices, it's
not just that the person taking it has a disease
and they're being treated. It's a mix between
they have a disease but they also have something
to share with the rest of their community.
The whole ibogaine experience is encapsulated
in a bunch of things that we as Western
doctors might dismiss as just ritual,
but include things like face painting and social
touch and the whole community is involved for this
three-day long trip that the person goes from one
house to another. It turns out that a lot of those
elements that we might not necessarily recognize
as important, that we might dismiss as ritual,
in a mouse, we can recapitulate. We know
that MDMA's ability to reopen the social
critical period is social-context dependent. If
we give it in isolation, then it doesn't reopen.
It turns out that there are all of these elements
that go beyond just the molecule and we can't
just import, take the thing that we decide
is the most important element, the molecule,
and import it into our medicinal practices and
our cultural history without understanding it
because many of those elements of the ritual
might be actually really important to how
these drugs are working therapeutically.
Unless we understand it from our context,
we won't be able to readily adapt them, I think.
Tim Ferriss: 100 percent. To maybe clarify the
point I was trying to make somewhat inelegantly,
I think all of these practices are worth studying,
especially the things that have had some degree
of longevity and persisted over time that seem to
be adaptive or could potentially, plausibly
be helpful in the therapeutic effects. And
I push back, maybe it's because I'm in
Austin and you can't throw a rock without
meeting someone who did a weekend online
course and is now a self-proclaimed shaman,
so I have a certain sensitivity to it.
But this romanticized, I think very
naive notion that you can just copy and paste
things whole cloth from one area to another
is not just naive but also quite dangerous.
And I appreciate you saying what you just said.
If you flash forward in your mind,
I recognize there's some imagination
and speculation required here, but if this
critical period work and maybe the offshoots
of that work continue to gain support
through rigorous science and evidence,
what might therapeutic interventions or
treatments look like 10 years from now?
I'm pulling that number out of nowhere. But
I'm curious to know in your mind's eye what
you think things could look like if this
continues to develop in the direction that
at least now you're pursuing research.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah. I think for me,
if this ends up being true, then it's going to be
a pretty big paradigm shift for neuropsychiatric
treatments because — let me just back up and
say I have to give a little bit of credit to
MAPS here because MAPS did a lot of really hard
work to convince the FDA that the way to design
clinical trials around psychedelics was to abandon
the one-variable-at-a-time test model and say,
"Look, we really need to pair these drugs
with psychotherapy because the drugs are
not doing the magic by themselves. It's
really this combination that's working."
That I think was a big shift in the way that the
FDA wants us to test drugs in clinical trials.
I think that we're beginning to see more and more
evidence that that context is really what matters.
For example, the clinical trials where context is
secondary, where the psychotherapy is essentially
there in case somebody has a bad trip, but it's
not really front and center to the intervention,
then I think those trials for psilocybin, for
example, aren't working as well as the trials
where it's really seen as an adjunct to the
primary therapy, which is the psychotherapy.
Now, if we're right and the critical
period reopening explanation is this
shift in the framework for how we understand these
therapeutic effects, then in 10 years from now,
the way that psychedelics are going to be used is
going to be trying to identify that right context
for the right disease. So while an inter-directed
trip with a lot of psychotherapy makes a lot of
sense for PTSD and addiction and depression,
it's probably the wrong context for stroke.
Whereas doing a lot of physical therapy and
movement and playing virtual reality motion
games might be the right context for giving the
psychedelic for stroke, for allergy maybe the
right context is snuggling up to that horse or
that dog or that cat that you're allergic to.
So I think the future, the therapeutic potential
for this is going to be — the opportunity is huge,
but the devil is going to be in the details
in terms of identifying the right context and
figuring out how to get activation of the right
neural circuit that's relevant for the brain
transformation that you want to see happen.
Tim Ferriss: If we take the case of stroke
patients, for instance, if we just assume for
the moment that we're using human subjects,
how might you think about currently what
type of experimental design you would use
with respect to dosing? Because if
you have this less inter-directed,
say, higher dose experience with a potential
for these noetic qualities that you described,
but rather you're following instructions, you are
practicing skills using, potentially, VR, do you
have any thoughts on how you design the study or
what the minimum effective dose might look like?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah. There are two
questions in there, let me just
pull them apart for a second. The dose issue,
our studies that we've done so far suggest that
there's a pretty narrow dose response for
reopening critical periods and that matches
what we see in humans for the acute subjective
effects. But we don't see any evidence that
increasing the dose necessarily increases the
opening of the critical period or how long the
duration of the critical period open state.
Basically, what we find is that if the acute
subjective effects are short, like with ketamine,
then the window only stays open for a very short
amount of time, less than a week. Whereas
if the window stays open for — if the acute
subjective effects lasts a really long time,
like with ibogaine which lasts 36 to 72 hours,
then the window, the critical period
window, stays open for much longer. In mice,
that's four weeks. In humans, that may translate
to four weeks or four months. We're not sure.
And then psilocybin, MDMA, and LSD are in the
middle there between those two extremes. But it's
not the case that if you double the dose of LSD,
then you can get LSD to open the critical period
longer, for example. So that dosing business, I
think, is going to be a little bit of a heartbreak
for all of the pharmaceutical companies out
there that are essentially trying to engineer
out the psychedelic effects by shortening
the duration of the psychedelic effects to
get less side effects and a shorter journey that
will be easier to manage in a clinical setting.
Again, what can you do? Nature is nature. But
I do think that it changes the model of how we
approach these. Rather than thinking of these as
next generation anxiolytics or next generation
anti-depressants or SSRIs, what we really need
to be thinking of these as is more like surgery.
If you have a heart attack, you go and you have
open heart surgery, it lasts for eight hours.
You have maybe two or three weeks afterwards
where you are required to be on bedrest and
take things easy. But then you're cured.
So who wouldn't rather be cured of a heart
attack than have to be on a medicine for the
rest of their lives? I think most people see
that as the major promise of psychedelics. So
in terms of the therapeutic approach, I think
the way I'm framing this stroke trial is really
I'm not worried about the fact that they're
going to have to do a psychedelic. Potentially,
the maximum benefit is going to be from these
long-acting psychedelics, because I think that
these motor critical periods are pretty strong
closes and so you want to reopen them for as long
as you possibly can to get the maximal effect.
We'll have to work out how to do them back
to back to back. But that's how I'm thinking
about it there. The second thing I want
to unpack about your question is that
you mentioned for the stroke that you were
imagining that we would be giving the psychedelic
and the person would be practicing a bunch of
things in a very specific, directed way. Actually,
that's not how I'm imagining that this will work.
Tim Ferriss: I got it. It would be more
sequential, not concurrent. It would —
Dr. Gül Dölen: No, no, no. It would be
concurrent, but I would say it's not going to be
practice-based. One of the things that I would
want to emphasize is part of the reason that I
paired up with Steve Zeiler and John Krakauer
at Hopkins is that their approach for treating
stroke during the normal one, the critical period
is already open, is that they've said, "Well, most
of the physical therapy that patients receive is
very goal directed. I need to learn how to zip my
pants with the other hand, I need to learn how to
comb my hair with the other hand."
So it's very much practical,
solving the problem another way, whereas the way
that we learn those motor patterns when we're
children is much more goal undirected to kind
of play, wandering, don't care if I fall down
a million times. I mean, there's this great idea
that children, when they're learning how to walk,
will walk the equivalent of seven football fields
in an hour. Now the only time I've ever seen an
adult do that is on MDMA. They will just dance
and they don't care if they look like fools.
They don't care if they're not good dancers.
It's not goal-directed. They're just enjoying
the play of doing the motion. What I like about
Steve and John's approach to motor rehabilitation
without psychedelics is that their virtual
reality system that they've built is very much
capitalizing on this non-goal directed, play-like
behavior. And I think that's going to be the key.
So I think if we can get people on psychedelics
plus put them in this motor play context,
then we can maximally recapitulate the
conditions that we learn how to do motor
function when we're developing as children.
Tim Ferriss: Speaking of fun, I want to
go back in time to Bears Lab at MIT. This is
from Spectrum News, reading a section of this.
"He had stressed the importance of science
being fun," and the quote is, "'If you lose
sight of the fun in science, it's hardly worth
continuing,' he used to say. Dölen decided that
if she was indeed going to give up a life of
science, she would go out on her own terms."
Could you unpack that last sentence?
Were you considering giving up a life
of science? Then how did that lead to
octopuses? Because it seems like that
focus then opened up Pandora's box in the
most positive way. I want to go back and
do a little bit of postmortem on what exactly
happened. So please, if you wouldn't mind,
just tell the story of that period.
Dr. Gül Dölen: When you start your own lab,
you get a bunch of money. That startup
package is great to get you started,
hire some people buy some equipment, get your
lab established without having to worry too
much about the funding. When I started my lab,
I got a nice startup package. I immediately got
a couple of private foundation grants which
were very helpful to help me establish the
lab. But you really can't, in academia, survive
unless you can also get funding from the NIH.
These big NIH grants, in my career, in my
lifetime, have gotten harder and harder to
get. It used to be that people who were young
and had a lot of creative ideas had much higher
success rates than people who were older and just
redoing the same experiments with the different
— whatever, very conservative rinse and repeat
type of experiments. Over my scientific career,
I have seen that situation essentially reverse. So
people over the age of 65 are getting most of the
NIH grants, junior people are really struggling.
There have been some attempts to correct that,
but they just haven't worked. It's just incredibly
difficult to get funding. Then if you add on top
of that, the funding has gotten so conservative
that basically the way that I write NIH grants
right now is — once I have all of the results that
are going to make a cool Nature paper, I write
a grant on all of the boring experiments that I
didn't do it for that paper but that I think that
the reviewers might ask me for, and I package
that together and I send that to the NIH.
That's how conservative my grants really are
when I applied to NIH funding. And that's been
successful. But there was a moment a few months
before the octopus paper, before we even did that
experiment, where I was just beginning to feel
like I'm not going to make it. I applied to the
NIH 17 times before I got my first NIH grant.
Tim Ferriss: Wow!
Dr. Gül Dölen: I think part of it was because Iwas
proposing these crazy ideas that people were like,
"There's no critical period for social behavior."
What? "Nobody's ever going to use psychedelics
clinically." What? "No, that'll never work.
Oh, you made those mice — too bad you didn't
use them for the experiment that I would've
used them for. You're just a junior person.
You have no established track record. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no." I was feeling really
demoralized and I was like, "I can't do this."
I thought I was becoming a scientist because I
was going to get to pursue these big questions and
be creative and steer my own ship. That's what I
had worked so hard for as a graduate student,
as a postdoc, as a medical student. That was
the dream that I was sold. I was pretty devastated
by how many rejections I got. In that moment when
I was like, "All right, I'm going to try a couple
more times, but if I don't get it I'm out as soon
as I…" My department was very supportive. They
were like, "You'll get there, you'll get there,
you'll get there. We'll cover you. Don't
worry, don't fire anybody. You're good."
But still, it's a blow to your ego if you can't
convince your peers at the NIH to give you that
money. So going out on my own terms, I was just
like, "Look, one of the creative — I've always
wanted to do study evolution. I've always
wanted to do something to do with marine
neuroscience. I have this opportunity to look at
what happens to this behavior in an octopus. I'm
just going to go for it and it'll be fun."
Even if it doesn't work, even if it
is not useful for my career in any way at all
— I mean, I would go to these meetings with the
faculty meetings and meetings with my department
chair, and I'd tell him we were planning to do
this octopus stuff, and he'd be like, "Gül, what
are you doing? We hired you to cure autism. What
is this octopus stuff? What?" And I'd just be
like, "Look, you've got to back off. This is
what I want to do. This is what's going to make
me feel like science is fun. I'm doing it not in
a goal-directed way, in a playful, just out of
curiosity. I just want to know what happens."
Then it worked and it revived my sense of
play and joy and feeling like you can do
those crazy experiments that everybody
thinks are crazy and have fun with it.
Tim Ferriss: So you, I wouldn't say bet
the farm, but you were willing to go out
in a blaze of glory and meaning just focusing on
fun and trying to break new ground. It worked.
How do you think about, if you do, preserving
that type of willingness? Maybe the octopus work
bought you a golden ticket to now continuing
to do work that is not rinse and repeat,
but perhaps — I'm just spinning a story here.
But I can imagine as you get more established,
maybe you feel like you have more to protect, so
maybe there's an inclination to take fewer risks.
How do you think about risk taking moving forward?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yeah. First of all, I
don't want to oversell how big of a risk it was
for me to do that experiment. We were already
working on MDMA, we already had reasonable
response from nature about the MDMA critical
period experiment. The octopus thing was really
kind of like — well, we had the MDMA around, and
I've always been curious and I just wanted to see
what would happen. Then a collaborator was like,
"Whoa! We have seven octopuses that we can lend
you for a week." And I was like, "Come on down."
He flew down, he slept on my couch. We stayed up
until two o'clock in the morning every night just
doing it, mad scientists, because we had to send
the octopuses back by the end of the week. It was
just like this mad scientist fun time. So how do I
preserve that? Well, I guess part of, I think, the
reason that we as scientists are seeing less and
less of that crazy stuff is really the funding.
Just to give a sense of this, I think this is
a really missed point, especially with tech.
In the '50s and '60s, the NSF,
the National Science Foundation,
and the NIH were funding all kinds of crazy
stuff that they just never thought would ever
be useful or have a goal. They were just
funding it. So when Thomas Brock was like,
"There are these weird bacteria that live in
these thermal vents in Yellowstone National Park,
give me some money to go figure out how
they can survive those temperatures,"
NSF was like, "Yeah, sure, here you go."
If they hadn't given him that money,
the PCR test that we all learned about during the
pandemic would not be possible because that enzyme
that is required for that test is made by those
bacteria that live in those weird thermal vets.
So I think this non-goal directed, curiosity-based
science, it doesn't show any usefulness for 40,
50 years. It takes that long for something
meaningful to come out of that discovery-based,
curiosity-based science. And I think that the
way that funding constraints and the way that
the tech and — even private foundations are very
goal-oriented. It's like, "Well, how can we sell
this? How can we market this?" And the private
foundations have names like Cure Autism Now.
They're very goal-directed. I think that that
kills the motivation or the impetus to just do
the weird stuff that's just for fun and curiosity.
I would say every person who becomes a scientist
at one point or another had that as their
motivation. The strain of the funding crisis
is essentially what has forced people to get
more and more and more conservative. So I don't
think I'm unique for wanting to just see what
happens when you give octopuses MDMA. In fact,
I think the reason that everybody responded
to that paper so well worldwide is because
every single one of us has that curiosity, has
that, "I wonder what would happen?" It resonated
with people, and I just think it mostly gets
beaten out of us because of funding constraints.
Tim Ferriss: Is there any solution there? I mean,
if you could wave a magic wand, are there any
structural changes that would help to alleviate
that? I'm just wondering if anything comes to mind
aside from just, "Come on, guys. Come on. We need
the exploratory stuff, the weird stuff. Otherwise,
we're not actually investing in the long-term
serendipity that has produced all of these
world changing technologies." Aside from
just having drinks with people at NIH or
NSF or elsewhere and having this conversation,
are there other levers that could be pulled or
other changes that could be made?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Well, I would say
that this is venturing off into politics, which is
a hobby, not my area of expertise. But I would
certainly say that if we look at the percentage of
taxpayer money that — well, first of all, in the
'50s and '60s, we collected a lot more taxes.
Today, we give away more in tax breaks than
the entire discretionary budget back to big
corporations as incentives and tax breaks.
But really, most of those corporations,
the thing that they are making and selling right
now, especially in the tech industry, really,
are possible because the taxpayers in the
'50s and '60s made those investments in
the science and technology areas to develop all of
the computing and software building, science, and
research that that stuff was built upon. Facebook
and all of these tech ventures that we — and
Google and cell phones and computers, they didn't
just happen to arise out of America for no reason.
They came because the United States for years
understood that this was an investment for
the way way future. So I think changing our tax
structure to reinvest in the future of science,
it's either going to happen or it's not. It's
going to move to other countries and places like
China that are investing in science and technology
in this non-goal directed, “just throw money at
it and eventually something cool will pop out”
attitude. I mean, that's just my two cents. I hope
I didn't insult half your audience, but —
Tim Ferriss: No.
Dr. Gül Dölen: — that's what I think.
Tim Ferriss: I don't think you've insulted
half the audience. I mean, I do think it's
important to say that, I mean, the priorities of
the government and nation state affect so many
different components of life and the future of
innovation in this country. If you do look back,
as you mentioned, to many of the innovations that
came out of, say, DARPA and other organizations
that were fundamentally funded by taxpayer
dollars, I mean, it is remarkable to look back
at how fundamental many of these technologies
have become. Switching gears and just ask a few
more questions. Do you have any books that you
have shared, recommended, or gifted the most
to other people or recommended often to other
people? Any favorite books that come to mind?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Oh, God. How did we wander into
this political sphere? Probably the ones that I
have gifted the most is a book called Invisible
Women by Caroline Criado Perez. I really love
it because I think it's a book of feminism that
is accessible and I think resonates with people
whether or not you're a man or a woman. It's just
data. It's like, "All right, well, here's how much
it costs to keep ignoring women. If you fix it,
your city can save a million dollars a year."
It's all about the structural stuff. It's not
about your feelings about whether women deserve
to be in the kitchen or not. It's not about that.
It's just here's how ignoring data about
women's body sizes, women's travel patterns
ends up costing society at large. I think it's an
excellent way of getting that. Then the other book
that I love the most, it's a very grandiose
title. It's called The Dawn of Everything:
A New History of Humanity by David Graeber.
I actually love everything that guy wrote.
I started with this book called Bullshit Jobs,
which — I was dealing with the bureaucracy of
academia and feeling very frustrated. I read
that book and it was very cathartic, and then
I just went down the rabbit hole and have enjoyed
all the other books. But The Dawn of Everything,
it's a big book and it's pretty thick, but the
last chapter has some really cool stuff about
psychedelic uses in other cultures. Then the third
one that I really love is The Immortality Key
by Brian Muraresku.
I love that book so much.
I designed my entire Halloween decoration this
year all around that book. I sent pictures of it
to Brian and he was like, "Oh, my God! You nailed
it. I've got to up my Halloween game." So yeah,
those are the three books that I would recommend.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. The Immortality Key is
the only of the three that I've read, but
fantastic book. Really, really exceptional.
It has made me want to try to meet archeo-chemists
and have more conversations about recreating the
elixirs of Midas and many others. We'll see if I
ever get around to that. I'll have to maybe cut
back on my podcasting to make time for that.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Well, I loved that book
also because there's a — my family's from Turkey,
and one of the places that he mentions is Ephesus,
which is an hour and a half
drive away from my mom's house.
Definitely, next time I go to Turkey, I'm visiting
Ephesus to try and figure out all those Hecate
carvings and maybe take a little soil sample.
Tim Ferriss: Just a little soil sample. Customs
love soil samples. Gül, this has been
a wonderful conversation. We've covered
a lot of ground. Is there anything else that
you would like to add? Any closing comments,
anything we didn't discuss that you'd like to make
mention of or draw attention to before we wind to
a close for at least this initial conversation?
Dr. Gül Dölen: God, I can't think of it. I think
this has been one of the most fun, meandering
conversations. I feel like we covered
everything. But I look forward to doing it again
sometime because I really do think that in the
next few years we're going to have some pretty
ground-shifting stories coming out and I would
love to come back and share them with you.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. Things are moving
quickly, things are developing quickly, and I
think we're going to have a lot of very exciting,
interesting, and provocative questions on the
forefront of science in the next few years, which
I'm looking forward to. I'm glad that you are
very willing and capable of challenging the maybe
dominant beliefs or the beliefs to get traction
and are willing to take risks with the science
that you pursue. So thank you for doing the work
that you do. Is the best place for people to find
your work dolenlab.org? Is that
where you would point people?
Dr. Gül Dölen: Yes. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Perfect. Well, teşekkür ederim! Thank
you for taking the time today.
Dr. Gül Dölen: Oh, wow! Excellent
pronunciation. Ben teşekkürler!
Tim Ferriss: Thank you. Yeah,
I love Turkey. I love Turkey.
The language I'm fascinated with,
that's a conversation for another time.
Very similar, grammatically, to Japanese,
oddly enough, which is where I've spent more
time. But I really appreciate you taking the time
today and being willing and so game to explore so
many different subjects. To everybody listening,
we'll have links to the various terms, stories,
people, names, books, et cetera that we discussed,
including studies, in the show notes as always
at tim.blog/podcast. Until next time, experiment
widely, be just a bit kinder to yourself and
others than is necessary. Thanks for tuning in.